يتفقد وزير الدفاع الروسي سير تدريب
المتعاقدين الجدد مع الجيش الروسي في
منطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه تؤكد هذه الزياره
الميدانيه لوزير الدفاع مدى اهميتها هؤلاء
المتعاقدين بالنسبه للجيش الروسي وتنبع
هذه الاهميه من رفض الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
اعلان التعبئه العامه واصراره على وصف ما
يجري في اوكرانيا بالعمليه الخاصه في
السابق لعبت الشركات العسكريه الخاصه وعلى
راسها فارغنر دورا مهما في ارسال مقاتلين
الى الجبهه الاوكرانيه يقدر موقع ملفار
جلوبال الذي يعنى بالبحث العسكري عدد
الشركات العسكريه الخاصه في روسيا بسبع
وثلاثين شركه احدى عشره منها ظهرت بعد بدء
الحرب على اوكرانيا من ابرز هذه الشركات
بالاضافه الى فاقنر
وانوت لكنه وزاره الدفاع امرت الشهر
الماضي المنتسبين لما تسميها وحدات
المتطوعين بتوقيع عقود معها بحلول نهايه
الشهر
خطوه وضعت ضمن المحاوله لكبح جماح مؤسس
فاغنن
التوقيعه تمرد انتهى بخروجه من المشهد
العسكري لكن المتحدث باسم كريم
عقود مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وبتزامن مع
ذلك وقع الرئيس الروسي قانونا يسمح بتجنيد
السجناء للخدمه العسكريه بموجب عقود ووقع
ايضا قانونا يرفع الحد الاقصى لسن الخدمه
التعاقديه اثناء التعبئه الى 70 عاما تظهر
هذه القرارات الحاجه الى مقاتلين تسميهم
روسيا متعاقدين وتسميهم اوكرانيا والدول
الغربيه مرتزقه نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي
قال ان وزاره الدفاع جندت منذ بدايه السنه
185 الف متعاقد وان حوالي عشره الاف
انضموا للجيش خلال الاسبوع الماضي بعد
تمرد فا لم يحدد من هم هؤلاء المتعاقدون
الجدد لكن الجميع يعرف ان مجموعه احمد
الشيشانيه قبل توقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في مايو الماضي قال الزعيم شيشاني
رمضان قادروف ان 7000 شيشان يوجدون فعلا
في اوكرانيا وانه يجري اعداد 2500
لارسالهم الى هناك الان يتهم قائد المنطقه
الشرقيه في الجيش الاوكراني روسيا بارسال
مرتزقه جدد بدلا من مقاتل فاغنر والايام
القادمه ستحدد مدى تاثير خروج فاجنر من
ساحه الحرب